it's the most exciting episode of the
ben shapiro show ever the democrats
finally ditched the faux friendship and
go for the jugular with michael
bloomberg squarely in their crosshairs
Bernie Sanders finally has to answer a
question about to let Colts and clover
chart and Buddha judge can't stop their
slap fights so much fun I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN protect your online
privacy today it expressvpn calm /ban
well wasn't that fun alright I don't
know what everybody's waiting months for
four months
these people are hugging each other was
a kumbaya circle we were waiting for
everybody would attack each other and
then last night finally it all broke
loose it turns out that all of these
erstwhile friends these people who love
each other and they're united in their
shared contempt for President Trump it
turns out they hate each other's guts
and if they had the ability to they
would actually carve out the small
intestines of their enemies and feed
them to the seagulls that's what was
happening last night on that Democratic
debate stage and it was glorious and it
was fun it was also unbelievably stupid
the reason it was unbelievably stupid is
because Bernie Sanders is the front
runner so naturally all the other
Democrats being complete utter effing
morons decide let's go after Michael
Bloomberg genius idea guys
genius idea so Bernie is gonna sweep the
primaries okay I'm predicting it right
here right now I will be shocked if
anyone wins two other primaries look I
think Bernie is now going to sweep to
the nomination I think Bernie wins
Nevada I think for anyone South Carolina
I think Bernie wins California I think
Bernie wins Texas I think Bernie wins
pretty much everything I think Bernie is
not only the front-runner I think he is
the presumptive Democratic nominee with
a majority of the delegates I do not
think this goes to an open convention
the reason for that is because all the
other Democrats are complete and utter
idiots they refuse to attack Bernie
Sanders instead they train their fire on
Michael Bloomberg for some odd reason
who has yet to win a vote and also
you're attacking the guy in the wrong
laney adults particularly Elizabeth
Warren so everybody's giving plaudits to
Elizabeth Warren today Elizabeth Warren
so let me just remind you yesterday what
did I say would happen with Elizabeth
Warren I suggested that Elizabeth Warren
would be this year's performer of the
presidential campaign ceremonial chris
christie marco rubio murder/suicide
right that's what happened in 2016 chris
christie was basically out of the race
he needed to do well in New Hampshire
Marco Rubio was rising Donald Trump was
sitting above the field and chris
christie instead of going after Trump
who's in his Lane decided I'm going to
go after Marco Rubio so you murdered
Marco Rubio on stage and then promptly
committed hari-kari himself and both of
them were out of the race but Rubio
stayed in and split the vote with Cruz
and so Trump sails to the nomination
last night Elizabeth Warren attacked the
person in the wrong
like the idiot she is instead of going
after Bernie whose voters she needs to
win over she decided what if I attack
Michael Bloomberg what if I just got for
Bloomberg
for no reason he's in the other Lane now
it does make you wonder about her
strategic acumen not only because she
attacks the person in the wrong lane but
because if Elizabeth Warren had any
brains at all she would have been in the
moderate Lane and she would now be the
chief rival to Bernie Sanders right
Elizabeth Warren had to make a choice
very early on in this campaign whether
she was gonna run in the moderate lane
or whether she was gonna run in the
progressive Lane and her choice was
basically rooted in who do I think is
more durable candidate Bernie Sanders or
Joe Biden and she chose Joe Biden she
said Biden is more durable candidate
he's gonna suck up all the attention in
the moderate lane Bernie is a non
durable candidate and so I will go into
his lane and I will take away his
support and for a little while that
worked and then she started to fade and
it turns out that Bernie was much more
durable than Biden and Biden fell apart
and he can see the opposite decision
made by people judge who could have
moved into the Bernie Lane and instead
with his Medicare for some plan moved
into the moderate Lane and started
sucking up attention from Joe Biden so
Elizabeth Warren made the wrong call now
it's too late for her but it's not too
late for her
to scalp somebody in her preferred
fashion so she decided to go out for
Michael Bloomberg last night that was
amusing it was amusing to watch as
Michael Bloomberg after a really
horrible 45 minutes on stage I mean his
his campaign basically admitted the
first 45 minutes he was it was a bleep
show
Bloomberg after the first 45 minutes
went after Bernie Bernie was Bernie it
had no answers to any tough questions as
always his the the main theme there's so
many themes of the show I mean I will
say my personal favorite part was the
was the tete-a-tete between Amy
Klobuchar and people who judge Klobuchar
for good reason cannot stand people to
judge and shoved him face-first into a
wood chipper last night and it was
glorious but one of the main themes last
night and this is gonna be a theme going
for is that Democrats are utterly
unprepared to run in a general election
because they've been protected by the
media and Bernie Sanders was an
excellent example of that last night
people were asked perfectly obvious
questions about the record my questions
I have asked on this program for years
that every conservative has been asking
for years and Bernie gets hit with like
the most obvious attack ever and he has
no response why because nobody in the
media has ever asked Bernie obvious
questions nobody in the media had asked
Elizabeth Warren obvious questions
or club achar or bootie Jetta so last
night all the knives came out and it
basically was knives out except there
wasn't the daughter of a new legal
immigrant to walk away with the fortune
there was it was just it was it was
wonderful and we're gonna get into all
of it every glorious vitally bloody
detail we're gonna get into all of it
just one second but first let's talk
about the necessity for the Second
Amendment so did you look at the
Democrats on stage last night and think
man if some of those people run the
country one of the things that they want
to do is violate all of my rights
including my Second Amendment rights
everybody on the stage last night is a
gun grabber all of them
and this is why I'm a supporter of the
Second Amendment yes the Second
Amendment exists to protect not only
your gun rights but protect you against
a government that would violate your gun
rights right these right to bear arms
protects you against violation of your
rights including the right to bear arms
owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility building a rifle is no
different started in a garage by a
Marine veteran more than two decades ago
bravo company manufacturing builds a
professional-grade product built to
combat standards this is because BCM
believes the same level of protection
should be provided to every American
regardless if they are a private citizen
or a professional ravel company
manufacturing is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer
manufacturer life-saving equipment the
people of BCM assume that when a rifle
leaves their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or a
soldier overseas so every components of
a BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
to a life-saving standard the folks at
BCM are wonderful their product is
wonderful learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm you can discover more
about their product special offers
upcoming nuzens got everything from
parts that you need for your rifle to
fully created rifles that is Bravo
Company MFG comm tons of great product
check them out right now you should
check out their awesome YouTube videos
as well and meet the people who make
their products at youtube.com slash
Bravo company you'll say awesome people
great Americans amazing products Bravo
Company
FG dot-com okay so let's jump right in
let's put this off no longer so the
first ten minutes of this debate where
basically let's line up Michael
Bloomberg injure shoot him that's it
that's what happened like Michael
Bloomberg they just put him center stage
and then every Democrat got to take a
potshot and Michael Bloomberg and Bernie
Sanders open it up he opened it up with
the typical Democratic attacks on stop
and frisk now the biggest problem for
Michael Bloomberg
is that he is not Donald Trump the
reason I say this is not because I think
that Michael Bloomberg is less rich than
Donald Trump
whether he's less in New York than
Donald Trump or anything like that the
reason that Michael Bloomberg's great
misfortune isn't is to be not Donald
Trump is not even because Bloomberg is
running in the Democratic Party whereas
Trump is running in the Republican Party
Donald Trump for better and for worse
many times for worse but often for
better is utterly unapologetic about who
he is utterly unapologetic about who he
is
Bloomberg could have used a little bit
of that last night because every attack
that was levied leveled against him last
night
could have been bracing down right he
could have just stood up to the attack
and later on in the debate by our - I
mean it's like a nine-hour debate by our
- he started to realize oh wait a second
if I stand up on my hind legs and
actually defend my record and defend
myself and defend my wealth and all of
this stuff that's better than me
cowering in the corner before the sjw's
on Twitter but he didn't know that
because his advisors had told him that
he needed to look like the nice guy out
there which is ridiculous and stupid so
Bernie Sanders opens this thing up being
a grumpy old communist and he's but by
the way you can just add that to any
sentence about Bernie Sanders who is the
absolute worst
he's just the absolute worst so Bernie
opens this thing up by attacking Michael
Bloomberg and he attacks him over
stop-and-frisk in order to beat Donald
Trump we're gonna need the largest voter
turnout in the history of the United
States mr. Bloomberg had policies in New
York City of stop-and-frisk
which went after african-american and
Latino people in an outrageous way that
is not a way you're gonna grow voter
turnout okay so this was an attack that
was he was hit on this several times
about stop and frisk his actual response
on stop and frisk II he you'll see later
he tries to apologize for his stop and
frisk position he's been trying this all
along his actual answer on stop and
frisk should not be to apologize for his
record it should be we lowered the
murder rate the beneficiaries of the
lowered murder rate were largely young
african-american and Hispanic males in
New York City we did something that is
legal and approved by the Supreme Court
of the United States none of you have
saved as many black and Hispanic lives
as my policies do so you can shove it I
mean that should've been his policy all
along right because let's be real about
this he's very popular in New York City
with black and Hispanic voters Michael
Bloomberg didn't have to kowtow to all
this nonsense
but he did and so I look bad Bloomberg
for his part went back at Sanders and he
just said out loud what most of the
Democrats know or at least believe which
is that Sanders has very little shot of
beating Trump he's an old commie I don't
think there's any chance of the senator
beating president Trump you don't start
out by saying I've got a hundred and
sixty million people I'm going to take
away the insurance plan that they love
that's just not a ways that you go and
start building the coalition that the
Sanders camp thinks that they can do I
don't think there's any chance
whatsoever and if he goes and is the
candidate we will have Donald Trump for
another four years and we can't stand
that so you're saying that out loud you
can see Lizabeth Warren's hand going up
because Elizabeth Warren could not wait
to jump into the fray last night
desperately vying for attention
desperately trying to reenact energy
into her campaign and so she was like
ready for this right this was her moment
and this is the moment she was getting
plaudits for should get plaudits all the
way until she's not in the race three
weeks from now okay because let's face
this Elizabeth Warren is toast she's
done she has no upside here everybody's
a halt Elizabeth Warren she finally
finally we saw the Elizabeth Warren she
was the leader in this race four months
ago you idiots and she faded because
she's terrible so last night she got
aggressive with Bloomberg and the left
likes that so now she's a heroine again
but they ain't gonna vote for her
instead of Bernie and then can a vote
for her instead of Buddha judge or club
a chart or Bloomberg or Biden by the way
who's still in the race dead man though
he is actual human corpse okay so here
was the much-ballyhooed
line in which Elizabeth Warren killed
Michael Bloomberg
I mean people actually went into
Wikipedia and they edited his date of
death as last night and his cause of
death is senator Elizabeth Warren her as
Elizabeth Warren going after Michael
Bloomberg I will tell you how Donald
Trump would have responded to this
because Donald Trump responded to this
exact same accusation okay and then
we'll see how what Michael Bloomberg did
to talk about who were running against a
billionaire who calls women fat broads
and horse-faced lesbians and no I'm not
talking about Donald Trump I'm talking
about Mayor Bloomberg
are not going to win if we have a
nominee who has a history of hiding his
tax returns of harassing women and of
supporting racist policies like
redlining and stop-and-frisk look I'll
support whoever the Democratic nominee
is but understand this Democrats take a
huge risk if we just substitute one
arrogant billionaire for another okay so
his response to all this was well I was
you know I told a few jokes back in the
day I told a few jokes back that's not
the way this works so Donald's from his
ass that's basically the exact same
question by megyn kelly in a Republican
debate remember this no you viewed
insulting women you sell these terrible
things about women and from Lynn only
Rosie only Rosie O'Donnell and even
people who didn't like Trump like okay
that that bleep hilarious really funny
so what if Michael Bloomberg had come
back and Elizabeth Warren said first of
all Elizabeth Warren you're a liar
you're lying about my record just like
you've lied about your own biography you
know you've just labeled me a racist and
a sexist but you say that you'll support
any Democrat including me so which is it
so you'll support a racist in a sexist
so is that really what you think of me
or are you just lying for political gain
also know you're going to talk about me
saying things about women and all of
this sort of stuff I would love to see
everything that you've ever said I'm
sure that you've said nasty things about
people there are things I've said that I
regret but are we really gonna run this
race on cutting people like schoolmarms
right the media would have hated it and
would have gone over gangbusters because
it turns out that when you stand up on
your hind legs in a debate that's what
you need to do instead Bloomberg play
dead every time he was attacked and he
he saw this over and over and over write
in a club a chart did the same thing she
attacked Bloomberg suggesting that it
was very bad because Michael Bloomberg
had said that all the other moderates
ought to get out of the race by the way
he's exactly right about this club achar
has no national aspirations she's done
Budi judge has no national aspirations
he has done Biden is gonna be finished
by South Carolina
everybody was ripping on him yesterday
about this memo that went out from his
campaign and the memo basically said
Bernie's gonna win the nomination unless
there is a consolidation around an anti
Bernie candidate there's only one end
head burning candidate with any momentum
and any money and as Bloomberg and he is
right say Amy Klobuchar got very very
angry about us we don't have to play her
but that attack is really dumb she she
finished her statement she said I
think you look at Donald Trump and say
we need someone richer in the White
House why why I seriously well I don't
understand why that's an attack why is
being rich an attack it seems to me that
we've had a fair number of very wealthy
presidents in the past who Democrats
like like FDR was not a poverty-stricken
individual I have a feeling that the
Democrats are just full of crap about
all this okay finally Bloomberg gets to
make the case for why he ought to be
President and his and his take is
basically that he is a manager not that
he has a vision but that he has a
manager no this is not a bad take it's
not a particularly bad take but it then
leads into more attacks on him so here's
here's Bloomberg defending his the
reason why he should be President I'm a
New Yorker I know how to take on an
arrogant con man like Donald Trump that
comes from New York I'm a mayor was a
mayor I know how to run a complicated
city the biggest most diverse city in
this country I'm a manager I knew what
to do after 9/11 and brought the city
back stronger than ever and I'm a
philanthropist who didn't inherit his
money but made his money and I'm
spending that money to get rid of Donald
Trump the worst president we have ever
had and if I can get that done it will
be a great contribution to America and
to my kids he's not the problem for
Bloomberg's of course he didn't look
like he had any fire in his belly at all
until he got to the second hour of the
debate
Peabody judge tried to edge his way into
all of this by posing himself as the
alternative to both Sanders and
Bloomberg right he's trying to take that
Biden slot he says those two you guys
that really polarizing his clip 7 he
says these two guys are super polarizing
but I am NOT polarizing I am the unity
candidate now as we will see Amy
Klobuchar later on in this debate she's
finally had enough of mayor Pete and it
just breaks him I mean she just breaks
him just takes out an east and baseball
bat and goes to work huh my favorite
portion of the debate by far anyway here
was Pete bootie judge trying to make the
case that the two most polarizing
figures in the party are Bloomberg and
Sanders again he's not wrong the theme
of this the theme of this show everybody
is right about each other and wrong
about themselves here is here is Pete
boo to judge we could wake up two weeks
from today the day after Super Tuesday
and the only candidates left standing
will be Bernie Sanders in Mike Bloomberg
the
two most polarizing figures on this
stage and most Americans don't see where
they fit if they've got to choose
between a socialist who thinks that
capitalism is the root of all evil and a
billionaire who thinks that money ought
to be the root of all power
ok-hee Boches the line right there but
it's actually not a bad line from Buddha
judge as we'll see however this did not
last this charmed moment for Buddha
judge that starts at the very beginning
yeah Amy Klobuchar took out a comb
sharpen and just went right for the
jugular we're gonna get some more of
this in just one second this glorious
debacle in the democratic debate last
night we'll get to that in one second
first are you feeling a little unsafe
after watching that debate I know that
all those candidates feel a little bit
less safe but are you feeling unsafe
because you live in let's say California
where the governor of California just
announced that we basically have a state
emergency
thanks to homelessness and their rising
levels of street crime and we've got all
sorts of problems property owners have
in my neighborhood breaking entering has
become a problem this is why you need
ring rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer you already know
about their smart video doorbells and
cameras that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world so if
there's a package delivery or a surprise
visitor you get an alert and you're able
to see hear and speak to them all from
your phone as a subscriber you have a
special offer on a wing whoa ring
welcome kit available right now at ring
comm so I got ring devices all over my
property to make sure that that ring of
security does exist around my property
I'm paranoid about security and by
paranoid I mean people are out to get me
and that's why I have rings security
devices all around the property it is a
good idea for you to do the same this
kit includes a video doorbell and a trim
Pro which is just what you need to start
building that ring of security around
your home the same way I have around
mine go to ring comm /ban that is ring
comm / button go check them out right
now ring.com
/ Ben okay so the stage has now been set
as I say what all the candidates last
night should have been doing was
attacking Sanders now Bloomberg because
Sanders is the front-runner lest we
forget
Sanders is leading by 10 points in the
national polling he is leading in Nevada
he is now even in South Carolina he's
leading in California he's leading in
Texas
Sanders is your leader in the clubhouse
right now and if Democrats keep going at
each other Sanders will be the nominee
and instead they launch like the softest
attacks ever the only person on the
stage credited to mayor Pete for at
least having an
political awareness to know where he's
supposed to be at the right time right
mayor Pete can't dunk politically like
he does not have the capacity to dunk
but he knows where to be to get the
rebound and and and that's smart right I
mean he knew where to be in sort of the
Democratic lanes he knew to go into
Biden's Lane and not into Sanders his
lane for example and he knew last night
that Sanders was the threat for the
nomination not Bloomberg and so he tried
to knock Sanders a little bit but he did
so with like the dumbest possible stuff
like instead of just bashing Sanders
over and over I'm being a communist
instead he decided to attack him for
being mean which is the wimpiest thing
ever the weakest attack on Bernie
Sanders is that the Bernie bros are mean
that sort of stuff is just weak T it
really is because it turns out then when
you have lots and lots of followers late
Bernie Sanders that some of those people
are gonna be hurt
okay so Buddha judge tried this anyway
this is clip ten so Sanders was asked
about why are your supporters so mean
and Buddha judge wouldn't let this go he
wanted to make it they that Sanders was
responsible for all of his supporters
which of course is a losing proposition
we have over ten point six million
people on Twitter and 99.9 percent of
them are decent human beings are working
people are people who believe in justice
compassion and love and if there are a
few people who make ugly remarks who
attack trade union leaders i disown
those people they are not part of our
movement senator when you say that you
disown these attacks and you didn't
personally direct them I believe you but
at a certain point you gotta ask
yourself why did this pattern or us why
is it especially the case among your
support I don't think it is actually yes
again this is just weak-kneed stuff from
from mayor Pete eventually any club
which are tired of this I keep pitching
this because it was fin freakin past
like I mean when she went after him it
was great we're gonna get to that
shortly and then Warren again jumping
into the fray so Warren jumped in shoes
basically like Leonardo DiCaprio with
the flame thrower and once upon a time
in Hollywood just spraying fire
everywhere for no apparent reason by the
way I mean really she's out of the race
but she is she's just going after
everybody she decides to go after Budaj
edge and Klobuchar and Bernie on health
care even though her health care plan is
the most unpopular one of
because she actually spelled out what
she meant and what she meant was
absolute nonsense here she was attacking
everybody Mirabeau de jedge really has a
slogan that was thought up by his
consultants to paper over a thin version
of a plan that would leave millions of
people unable to afford their health
care it's not a plan it's PowerPoint and
Amy's plan is even less it's like a
post-it note insert plan here has
started very much has a good start but
instead of expanding and bringing in
more people to help instead his campaign
relentlessly attacks everyone who asks a
question or tries to fill in details
about how to actually make this work and
then his own advisers say it probably
won't happen anyway okay everything
she's saying is basically true but it is
hilarious to say Bernie attacks everyone
and she's literally attacking every
single person on the stage every single
person like one by one then you get the
cutaways of them
mayor pickling and anemic low gurgling
and and Pete and Bernie Sanders going
just fantastic fantastic stuff so as I
say all of this is ancillary to the main
point which is that everybody was
attacking Bloomberg last night and as I
say because Michael Bloomberg is not
Donald Trump and because he apologizes
for everything in the first 45 minutes
it was a bad night for him here is a
perfect example of that
clip 13 Michael Bloomberg talked about
stop and frisk and he talks about how
embarrassed he is by one of the policies
that brought down crime dramatically in
his own City well if I go back and look
at my time in office the one thing that
I'm really worried about embarrassed
about was how it turned out with stop
and frisk okay that is such a mistake
and and this was the first 45 minutes of
there mate
again as we'll get to Bloomberg actually
issued a statement after the made bit
saying well first 45 minutes knock but
then it was good brilliant dude
brilliant in just a second when he got
two more of the Rock'em Sock'em robots
that took place last night was just
ridiculous ridiculous ridiculous stuff
Bernie Sanders emerges as the clear
front-runner at this when he already was
going in nobody
touched him really Bloomberg hit him not
sure how telling it's gonna be we'll get
to them there's even more fun stuff guys
it's so much fun what gets at so many
great moments it's like I'm doing
trailers for the movie we're gonna get
to it in just one second first it's
super easy to get into credit card debt
it really is right you start off you
take a bit you take on a little bit
credit card debt then you figure okay
I'll pay it off and they get just a
little bit behind and then those credit
card charges start racking up and
racking up and racking up what you need
to do if you are a responsible person
you've gotten into credit card debt is
consolidate those loans the best way to
do this get a credit card consolidation
loan from light stream rates are as low
as 5.95 APR with auto pay much lower
than the national average interest rate
on credit cards which can be over 20%
APR get a loan from $5,000 to $100,000
with absolutely no fees light stream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience that's
exactly what they delivered here's how
one of their customers describes their
experience quote I heard the radio ad
said it was worth looking at I was a
little skeptical because I'd never done
anything like this online before it's my
great surprise the loan process was
simple and easy to navigate through I
wish all loans were this efficient again
if you're racking up that credit card
debt it can really be a burden on you
and on your family instead go get it
solved by checking out light stream comm
my listeners right now can apply to get
a special interest rate discount and
save even more the only way to get the
discount light stream calm / Sapiro that
is lig HT stre am calm / Shapiro's light
stream calm / capiro subject credit
approval rate includes 0.50% auto pay
discount terms and conditions apply
offers are subject to change without
notice
visit light stream calm / capiro for
more information already so the the
Rock'em Sock'em robots continued and
again it was mostly attacks on bloomberg
just mostly attacks on bloomberg so
bloomberg does that apology he does that
little apology / stop and frisk and
elizabeth warren is having none of it
because she was just a hammer last night
all she was interested in was breaking
things not helping her campaign not
going after the person who actually has
all of her voting based bernie sanders
but again performing that chris christie
marco rubio ritual murder-suicide on
stage elizabeth warren clip 15 when the
mayor says that he apologized listen
very closely to the apology the
which he used is about to stop and frisk
it's about how it turned out
now this isn't about how it turned out
this is about what it was designed to do
to begin with and brown men from the
beginning and if you want to issue a
real apology then the apology has to
start with the intent of the plan as it
was put together and the willful
ignorance day by day by day of admitting
what was happening even as people
protested in your own Street shutting
out the sounds of people telling you how
your own policy was breaking their lives
you need a different apology this is why
Michael Bloomberg should never have
apologized look he's a
what Bloomberg should have done is you
should have said senator Warren you're a
damn liar if your suggestion is that
stop and frisk was specifically designed
to go after black and Hispanic men
you're gonna have to explain why we
saved so many black and Hispanic lives
with stop and frisk policy it was not
designed to go after black and hispanic
men it's ridiculous I'm sorry it's
ridiculous on his face policies that are
designed to go after black and Hispanic
men are ones that are specifically
designed about for black and Hispanic
men now policies approved by the Supreme
Court as aspects of the Fourth Amendment
when there's reasonable suspicion that a
person is carrying a gun in violation of
the law in New York City for example
Bloomberg should have just called her a
liar on stage but instead he decided to
pansy out and he opinion paid the price
for he did it again he did this again
and again with more this is what killed
him last night
so here's Elizabeth Warren going after
Bloomberg on his NDA's now I'll tell you
what Bloomberg should have said yeah no
he didn't excellent comeback available
to him but he didn't use it because
instead he was pan seeing out because
either he or his advisers believed that
if he could just sort of weather the
storm all would be well
which really does raise the question why
did this idiot bother to do the bait in
the first place like you're gonna drop
300 million dollars in ads why do you
need to be on stage what if you just
said listen I'm not I'm not getting in
this clown car with these idiots I'm not
doing this thing I'm not getting in this
in this reservoir dogs' warehouse like
why would I do that I'm just gonna stand
over here and you guys murder each other
and then when Super Tuesday comes we'll
see how you do and Donald Trump did that
by the way there
debate the Donald from fully skipped cuz
he didn't feel like doing it Bloomberg
could have done that he's not on any of
the ballots for two weeks but instead he
decided to jump in early and he got
clobbered for it here's Elizabeth Warren
and Michael Bloomberg being just an
absolute about defensive his own
conduct which again let me explain
something there's nothing wrong with
non-disclosure agreements non-disclosure
agreements are feature of every business
they're a feature of a business because
when you run a large business with a lot
of employees with large amounts of gross
money running through them it turns out
people sometimes have sometimes have an
incentive to spill information that they
believe will benefit them after they
leave your employ which they are not
entitled to and or sue you for reasons
that are unsubstantiated in order to get
a settlement from you this is why NDA's
exists this is why confidentiality
provisions exist every single company in
America with more than 10 employees has
them every single one a Bloomberg could
have said that and what he should have
said is you should have said to
Elizabeth Warren and by the way you'd
know that if you'd ever run a business
get idiot alright if you knew if you'd
run a business you would know that NGA's
are a part of every agreement and no I'm
not going to waive the requirements of
the NDA's so that a bunch of people who
now more than ever are politically and
financially driven to spill information
about my company that either is taken
out of context or damaging for the
perusal of people like you know I'm not
releasing people from NCAA's I've run a
business when you're on a business you
can decide how you are in a business but
no I'm not gonna pretend that everybody
who makes an allegation against my
business is telling the truth because
that's not true again anyone who's ever
run a business understands that when you
are a business with a large amount of
money flowing through you this is now a
big bag of cash that people sometimes
see as a way of grabbing a little money
by violating an NDA by threatening a
lawsuit by making allegations that are
unsubstantiated this stuff this stuff
happens all the time why do you think
places have HR departments HR
departments exist specifically for this
bloomberg should have said no one here
has run a successful business or any
business for that matter so no I'm not
gonna take advice on business from you
Elizabeth Warren you useless
you useless lady I'm not gonna take any
piece of advice on business from you
there's a reason I'm worth 60 billion
dollars and you are worth a classic full
of Ann Taylor Loft leftovers I mean that
that's that's what he should have said
but that's not what he says instead
instead he goes to
well I don't know no no just dumbassery
Ohio order from Michael Bloomberg here
he has gotten some number of women
dozens who knows to sign non-disclosure
agreements both for sexual harassment
and for gender discrimination in the
workplace so mr. mayor are you willing
to release all of those women from those
non-disclosure agreements so we can hear
their side of the story we have a very
few non-disclosure agreements none of
them accused me of doing anything other
than maybe they didn't like the joke I
told and let me just let me put theirs
would be agreements between two parties
that wanted to keep it quiet and that's
up to them they sign those agreements
and we'll live with it I just want to be
clear some is how many when you and when
you say they signed them and they wanted
them if they wish now to speak out and
tell their side of the story about what
it is they allege that's now okay with
you you're releasing them on television
tonight some of the company and somebody
else in this case the man or a woman or
could be but more than that they decided
when they made an agreement that they
wanted to keep it quiet for everybody's
interest I said we're not going to get
to end these agreements because they
were made consensually and they have
every right to expect that they will
stay hey he's getting openly booed about
all of this again his best answer here
is I run a business you don't run a
business because you're stupid because
you're a government service hack because
you've spent your entire life writing
bullcrap about bankruptcy that's
unsubstantiated so how about this how
about I handle my business and you
handle your business and I explained to
you in very basic terms using small
words and short complete sentences what
a nondisclosure agreement is and you
everybody on this stage all use who
don't understand how business worked you
shove it right that's exactly what he
should have said but of course he
wouldn't say that instead he goes to
well know they can sense it too the
non-disclosure agreement and so we're
gonna we're gonna hold to that and so
Elizabeth Warren asks the obvious
follow-up question okay what if they
want to get out of it now willing to let
them out of it
like no I'm not so then it isn't about
current consent right now it's about
they signed an agreement when he should
say is of course they signed an
agreement that is condition of
employment for all the reasons I have
already listed but again Bloomberg
wouldn't stand up for himself he
wouldn't it was only very especially
against Warren it was only very late in
the debate he stood up for himself and
then it got kind of good okay meanwhile
Peabody judge and Amy Klobuchar aren't
despise one another
despise one another and it is amusing
very amusing yes I'm gonna give you just
a taste of this okay so here's Pete
Buddha judge okay so here's my problem
people who judge people who judge is
more produce than Taylor Swift right
everything about people who judge is
produced from all of his stories about
like oh I learned Norwegian in order to
read a novel to here I am the mayor of
South Bend Indiana a small town but
really a microcosm of America the things
like like self in Indiana I'm sure it's
Pleasant South Bend Indiana has about as
many members as my as my synagogue like
there are a hundred thousand members of
South Bend Indiana
he got eight thousand votes okay and and
so his his thing has been that he is
essentially a Boy Scout and an
untouchable Boy Scout at that and that
he is perfect he is perfect his never
made a mistake people who judge ever in
his entire life no mistakes
okay so he decides to go after Amy
Klobuchar on the stupidest possible
topic his like something that gets under
his skin what gets under people's judges
skin that Amy Klobuchar was asked over
the last few days whether she knew the
name of the President of Mexico and she
admitted that she did not for the record
his name is Andres Manuel Luis Lopez
Obrador
okay that is his name but who cares like
honestly who cares people make mental
flubs all the time also easy answer to
this question if you don't know the name
of a president of a foreign country you
are vying to be President of the United
States you know it's more important that
they know your name that they know your
name cuz merica okay that's a perfectly
fine answer an acceptable answer you
don't know something about like the
president of Botswana
and you're like yeah I don't know his
name that's why I have a State
Department and we get together I'm sure
I'll know his name and we'll have good
conversations okay but people who judge
decides to go after Amy Klobuchar as
though she's stupid and Amy Klobuchar I
was having none of it and she basically
picks up the podium and hits him with it
what you're staking your candidacy on
your Washington experience
you're on the committee that oversees
border security you're on the committee
that does trade you're literally in the
part of the committee that's overseeing
these things and we're not able to speak
to literally the first thing about the
politics of the country to ourselves are
you trying to say that I'm dumb are you
mocking me people sometimes forget names
he's basically saying that I don't have
the experience to be President of the
United States I have passed over 100
bills as a lead Democrat since being in
the US Senate I am the one not you that
has won statewide in congressional
district after congressional district
and I will say when you tried in Indiana
pede to what run what happened to you
you lost by over 20 points to someone
who later lost to my friend Joe Donnelly
so don't tell me about experience I got
by the way it got better than that that
was not even the best clip of Amy
Klobuchar just turning full-on fargo and
feeding him face-first into a wood
chipper and richly deserved because that
is a dude who loves himself I mean
people who judge is self-righteous
beyond all possible measure and Amy
Klobuchar I was having none of it okay
I'll get to more of this in just one
second because this is the bevy of ads
for Donald Trump against Democrats then
Donald Trump was a big winner last night
there's no question of all the winners
last night Donald Trump was one the
other presumably was Marianne Williamson
who may still be the nominee depending
on if people turn their hearts to lights
and away from darkness but we'll get to
all of this in just one second first
let's talk about one of the ways that
you get healthier and that is you got to
change your habits you know people will
talk about workout people talk about
diet but the fact is unless you're
willing to change how you think about
workout and diet unless you're willing
to change the habits that shape how you
act none of it's gonna matter and this
is why you need new new MS they have a
changing solution that helps users learn
to develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses Noom
doesn't tell you what to do and what not
to do it teaches you how to look inside
your own mind and make better decisions
for yourself it's as much psychology as
it is working out nutrition NUMA is one
of the biggest most accurate food
databases available lets you track meal
habits visualize portion sizes and see
calorie density at a glance we're all
strapped for time
NUMA asks you to commit just 10 minutes
a day for yourself I've used noon
personally my pair
personally it has helped me drop a
little bit of weight it's helped me make
sure that the habits in which I am
engaging are good for me you don't have
to change everything in one day small
steps make big progress sign up for your
trial today at noon that's N oom comm
slash Shapiro you have nothing to lose
the weight may be some bad habits visit
numa comm / Shapiro to start your trial
today that is n oom comm / / I'm a big
advocate of healthy living go check out
Noom comm a / Shapiro and start that
trial today
ok if you thought the lead-up to 2016
was insane uhm you ain't seen nothing
yet the best place to keep you up to
date on all the insanity right here at
daily wire if you're not a member you
are missing out on a ton of amazing
content two new features right now
you'll get 10% off any membership plan
you choose when you use promo code
Shapiro members get our articles add
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full 3
hours of the Ben Shapiro show select
bonus content access to the mailbag and
more plus a new all access to your gets
you into exclusive live online Q&A
discussions with me Andrew Klavan matt
walsh michael moles plus daily where
writers and special guests don't forget
you'll also get the greatest of all
beverage vessels the leftist here's
tumbler again that's 10% off any plan
when you use a promo code Shapiro head
on over to daily wire today and join the
party that's daily wire calm and use
promo code Shapiro for 10% off any plan
great deal daily wire calm come join us
here at the fast the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so in this debate eventually began to
dawn on Michael Bloomberg that he was
going to have to actually defend himself
that it was not good for him to be lying
flat out in a spread eagle waiting to be
attacked and fed upon by the harpies of
the Democratic Party so this began I
think when he started to realize that
Bernie Sanders is actually a danger okay
so that like one of the things that
Bernie said in the middle of this debate
which will lose him Pennsylvania is he
said he wants a full-on ban on fracking
good luck with that you don't need jobs
fracking provides in Pennsylvania
he's more than coal in West Virginia I
mean when you talk fracking in
Pennsylvania not only are you talking
about an excellent industry that has
actually lowered carbon emissions the
substitution of natural gas via fracking
for oil in the United States means that
we are the world's number one decrease
er of carbon emissions over the past
several years it also provides tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of jobs in places like Pennsylvania here
is Bernie Sanders openly announcing that
he's gonna ban fracking nationwide good
luck winning swing states with us you
want a total ban on that natural gas
extraction fracking in the next five
years what do you tell these workers
it's supporting a big industry right now
sir
well are tell these workers is that the
scientists are telling us that if we
don't act incredibly boldly within the
next six seven years there will be
irreparable damage done not just to
Nevada
not just Vermont or Massachusetts but to
the entire world
luck with all this good luck with us
finally Bloomberg has had enough of this
and he says listen you know you guys
keep talking about business in the
economy and you're all horrible at this
like horrible at it he says if you're
gonna talk about business maybe you
might want to talk about the person who
earned a buck like who's actually not a
ward of the taxpayers here's Bloomberg
finally deciding that he's had enough of
this nonsense what I was gonna say but
maybe want to talk about businesses I'm
the only one here that I think the SEVIS
started the business is that fair okay
and everybody goes silent because of
course none of them have ever started a
business okay that should make a
difference that doesn't mean that you
have to start a business to be a great
politician it does mean if you've never
had any experience of the business but
you're telling every business owner in
America you know it's best for the
economy in your business maybe you
should shut up a little bit and read a
book for God's sake
man Bloomberg eventually was not having
it directly from Sanders Sanders goes
after Bloomberg and suggests that
Bloomberg is responsible for corrupt
politics in America and Bloomberg's like
um dude you've been in the Senate since
1637 here's here's Bloomberg going right
back at Sanders you know when we talked
about a corrupt political system bought
by billionaires like mr. Bloomberg it
manifests itself in a tax code in which
not only is Amazon and many are the
major corporations some owned by the
wealthiest people in this country not
paying a nickel in taxes we have the
insane situation that billionaires today
if you could believe it have an
effective tax rate lower than the
middle-class tax code why are you
complaining he's exactly right lemon
he's like what are you talking about you
were there you jerk like what do you
you're gonna complain like you weren't
part of the system you are the system
this is one of Bernie's great charms is
that he can be in Washington DC as part
of the system for his entire adult life
and then pretend that he was absent
somewhere maybe he was maybe he was busy
drinking shirtless in the Soviet Union
it didn't stop there bloom Bloomberg
finally I mean he had had enough he had
had enough clip 25 here is Sanders doing
me Michael Bloomberg didn't earn his
money it was all the workers at
Bloomberg corn the money through there
not investing in any of the equipment
taking any of the risk and earning a
pretty generous salary from Bloomberg
who did pay quite well as the employer
over at Bloomberg I mean this is
well-known
Bloomberg's company paid great income
but here is here is Sanders going after
Bloomberg and suggesting that Sanders is
greedy because of course it Bloomberg
has mom Sanders saying the Bloomberg is
great because Bloomberg has money mr.
Bloomberg wasn't you who made all that
money maybe it workers play some role in
that as well
those workers are able to share the
benefits also when we have so many
people go to work every day and they
feel not good about their jobs they feel
like cogs in a machine I want workers to
be able to sit on corporate boards as
well so they can have some say over what
happens to their lives absolutely not I
can't think of a ways that would make it
easier for Donald Trump to get
re-elected and listening to this
conversation
[Applause]
we tried that the countries tried that
was called communism and it just didn't
work
oh and then it warren oh you said
communism oh no we're not communist and
then Bernie goes oh no we like then luck
it's just like Denmark really sudden why
have you spent your entire adult life
defending communist regimes like people
like oh that's an unfair hit by that is
a perfectly fair hit by Bloomberg
Sanders is a commie
he is not a social democrat he is not
he's not his entire career has been
spent defending communist dictatorships
many aspects of communist dictatorships
ranging from their health care systems
so the way they treat their workers to
bread lines yeah you don't get to play
that card good for Bloomberg good from
Bloomberg and then Bloomberg gets in
what was the best hit of the night like
everybody's ignoring this because there
were so many hits early against
Bloomberg and really the first hour of
the debate matters the most cuz that's
when the most people are watching but
the most brutal hit of the night was
this hit by Michael Bloomberg on Bernie
Sanders it just demonstrates full scale
nobody in the media knows what they are
doing or at least if they do they're
garbage at their jobs garbage hot
flaming dumpster fires of garbage entire
landfills on fire of garbage half of
Earth on fire filled with garbage that
is the media because let me be frank
about this I do not know a conservative
in America who has not made some
comments about the fact that Bernie
Sanders has a lake house this is a
fairly obvious attack on a man who
claims that billionaires are bad who
used to claim the millionaires and
billionaires are bad but then he became
a millionaire and then he started
defending millionaires then he was like
nothing about the gun ride the book
everybody couldn't have a leg coast and
say oh welcome to the party Bernie the
old commie bastard you he's a Bloomberg
finally had had enough again this was
the it was great Bloomberg finally was
like okay
eff this man
done if this had been Bloomberg all
night by the way he actually would be a
front-runner but he was not he was
apologetic for the first two-thirds of
the debate here is Bloomberg going after
Bernie with a hatchet and Bernie has no
answers the most obvious question ever
asked to Bernie Sanders because the
media have been acting as both his
shield and his spear
here's Bloomberg asking the most obvious
question in human history and Bernie
having no answer because it's great to
be an old commie the left will defend
you to the death including members of
the media in the country happens to be a
millionaire with three houses what'd I
miss here well you worked in Washington
house watch the first problem live in
Burlington house too
that's good and like thousands of other
poor markets I do which PACs which tax
haven New York City thank you very much
okay I mean Bernie has no answer to that
how does he think that's an answer like
how does he even think that's a good
answer
it's amazing his friend said I have one
in Washington and woman Vermont and I
have a summer camp really like a full
camp out there like with kids and swings
and everything I'm a stomach comp by the
way it's not just a summer home it's
like a $600,000 lakefront property so
that was pretty fantastic it really was
and he is correct
Bernie is a rich human he's a rich human
with a summer home and I promise you
that if the Democrats think that's going
away Donald Trump will go to Bernie
Sanders's lake house he will pry up a
board from the floorboards he will bring
it to a debate and he will beat Bernie
to death with it figuratively speaking
he will do if you think that that's the
last time Bernie's heard about the lake
house you got a lot of things wrong
about modern American politics my friend
because Bernie deserves every bit of
that every bit of it
but as I said my favorite moments of the
debate actually was was not even that
that was pretty great there been a lot
of great moments clip 29 this is my
favorite moment this is when Amy
Klobuchar finally decides that she's
already decided she's had enough of a
Pete that this little pipsqueak was he's
won eight thousand votes in Indiana
being the moderate choice
well simultaneously Lake in 2000 the man
wrote like a full paper on the wonders
of Bernie Sanders his socialist agenda
he is not a moderate in any way Amy
Klobuchar finally was like okay you know
all of this all of this put together
Taylor Swift
kind of stuff like enough of that here
is a here as a me club which are
dropping the bomb on Pete we stood up
for those rights and stood with members
of our community with the message that
they were as American as we are but let
me tell you what it's like to be in the
arena and you can see how mad he is he's
so mad because she's right she's right
mayor Pete's never had to do anything he
fixed sidewalks in Indiana in Indiana
okay so it was glorious all the way
around final analysis big winners and
big Lunars and big losers big winner
obviously Donald Trump my President
Trump is obviously the big winner in all
of this President Trump
they issued his Trump world issued a
statement with Kayle mcenany issuing
this the statement the Democratic Party
is in the midst of a full-scale meltdown
Americans are watching the party of JFK
be torn apart by anti job Socialists and
anti worker globalist who want to
control every aspect of Americans lives
this trainwreck is nothing compared to
what they would do to our country none
of these candidates will be able to go
toe-to-toe with President Trump in
November
fact-check true Bernie Bloomberg Michael
Bloomberg announced in a statement yeah
our first 45 minutes suck hey I should
put out a statement you know you're a
winner when you are drawing attacks from
all the candidates everyone came to
destroy Mike tonight it didn't happen
everyone wanted him to lose his cool he
didn't do it he was the grown-up in the
room it took Mike just three months to
build a stronger campaign than the rest
of the field has built in more than a
year it took him just 45 minutes in his
first debate in ten years he had his
legs onstage that is an admission that
his first 45 minutes stunk it's a
disaster area out there and Joe Biden by
the way remember Joe you know even
played a single clip with Joe because
he's dead
I regret to announce that Joe Biden is
officially deceased
maybe the reports of his death are
premature but I think not I think he may
not in fact be a living human being
he's already downplaying the idea that
he has to win South Carolina which means
he's just gonna carry this thing on good
luck to him
Bernie's gonna be the nominee guys
that's the bottom line Bernie's gonna be
the nominee Elizabeth Warren decided to
kill everyone except for Bernie Bernie
decide to go out for Bloomberg and
Bloomberg appropriately hit him back
Pete and Amy were busy fighting with
each other
a lot of the all of the honeymooners I
mean it was just it was it was really it
was really great it was really great to
see the only downside is bringing an old
commie as the head of the Democratic
parties or good luck - good luck to all
of us each and every one - I need them
okay time for a quick thing that I like
and then we'll do a quick thing that I
hate so things that I like that whole
debate like really is great really
entertaining why could we have not had
that why could we have not had that like
the whole time but other things that I
like there's a movie that was reviewed
poorly because people don't like basic
patriotic American movies anymore and
you're not allowed to make them I
mentioned this about Air Force One the
other day that if Air Force one were
made today people would be saying
jingoistic terrible now if you made it
during a Democrat administration then it
would be wonderful remnant reminding us
what makes America great
okay well another one of these movies
that that was recently made was a movie
called Midway Roland Emmerich who did
Independence Day did it and movies
pretty great it really is it's enjoyable
okay it's not just enjoyable it's
historically accurate
it basically is about it's about the
Battle of Midway but basically it takes
you from Pearl Harbor all the way
forward to the Battle of Midway tracing
a bunch of the key figures and it is
history fact-filled well-shot well-acted
it's good it's a good movie the critics
didn't like it because it was too
straightforward but they want is that
America was bad in the Pacific unless
people forget the Japanese Imperial Army
was pretty brutal vicious and evil and
this movie doesn't let you forget it
here is a here a little bit of the
trailer for Midway
we need to throw a punch so they know
what it feels like to be hit
we're talking about a couple dozen
planes it's all Japanese fleet
this isn't a fair fight
by the way it is true that if the United
States loses the Battle of the Midway
very good shot the United States does
not actually win world war two and that
at least the west coast of the United
States is under direct attack so people
forget about battle in the Midway they
remember you know Jima because the
famous imagery they remember all the
battles in Europe the Battle of the
Midway because the naval battle doesn't
get the kind of attention that it should
so go check out go check out Midway so
available on rental today and it is
quite good it's definitely definitely
worth the watch very enjoyable very
patriotic the kind of movie that you
didn't think that Hollywood would make
anymore
pretty pretty pretty great stuff okay
time for a thing that I hate I live in
California my state is garbage my state
is just terrible I have the right to say
that it's a hellhole I can say that
because I've been here my entire life I
was born in California I was raised in
California I was married in Calvin was
married in Israel and California and and
I've lived my entire life in California
really like except for three years where
I was in Cambridge Massachusetts hanging
out with the the Elizabeth Warren crew
except for that I've been in California
my entire life and it is getting
progressively worse and I use the word
progressively advisedly because the more
progressive it grows the Dumber it grows
so we decided we were going to elect an
idiot Kendall as the as the governor of
the state of California this Kendall
said he was gonna solve homelessness in
San Francisco and completely failed to
do so instead helping turn San Francisco
into a poop filled needle mess and then
we were like oh let's make him governor
and he has presidential aspirations does
gavin newsom so gavin newsom gave his
State of the State address the other day
and in his State of the State address he
addressed the fact that California has
become the world's leading center of
homelessness or at least the America's
leading center of homelessness we have
by the way something like 65,000
homeless people counted in Los Angeles
County alone like Dodger Stadium worth
of homeless people in LA County you
cannot walk down the street any Street
in Los Angeles without people engaging
in public urination or defecation or
needle use they you I believe it was
Herbert Hoover who promised a chicken in
every pot in LA they promised a homeless
person on every bench there great
solution was that they were gonna put
bars on the benches like in the middle
of the bench that homeless people can't
actually lie across the benches and it
turns out that human beings being
adaptable homeless people missions
thrown blankets
those bars and they just sleeping right
over him like they don't really care so
it's because it's a wonderful city and
we pay exorbitant taxes and California
as a state we pay unbelievably high
taxes the highest tax rates in the
nation 13.3 top income tax bracket and
it kicks in and like I think a hundred
thousand dollars a year or something
it's it's very very low kickin anyway
gavin newsom it gave his State of the
State address in which he said it was a
disgrace we have so much homelessness
conveniently forgetting that um he is
the governor and was also the mayor of
San Francisco and is horrible at both
jobs let's call it what it is
it's a disgrace that the richest state
in the richest nation succeeding across
so many sectors is falling so far behind
to properly house heal and humanely
treat so many of its own people every
day the California Dream is is dimmed by
the wrenching reality of families
children and seniors living unfed on a
concrete bed
okay well I'm you know who's responsible
for that that would be like a you and
the Democrats who have run Sacramento
virtually my entire adult lifetime and
you may have something to do with that
do you not so what proposals did Gavin
Newsom bring to the table on
homelessness well as a Ken doll there's
not a lot between the ears so Gavin
Newsom brought a few proposals here's
one of his proposals he says what if we
just like said that people have a legal
right to shelter what if we just said
that now last I checked when you say
somebody has a legal right to a thing
this carries with it a couple of
implications one either nothing happens
because you declared it right and it
doesn't materialize for example there's
a right to housing in the South African
Constitution homelessness in South
Africa a very large thing you can
declare anything right that doesn't mean
it materializes if I declare the other
right to pancakes this morning I'm not
gonna make it the pancakes nobody's
gonna make any pancakes the ban case
ain't gonna appear if I declare the over
right to housing that does not make the
housing appear or is Gavin Newsom saying
that if you have a legal right to
housing you can now sue the state to
provide you the housing which means that
the state will be forced to raise taxes
to build the housing or does it mean
that the state can force developers to
rent out their properties at rates that
are non beneficial lowering development
causing increased taxes causing
increased spending on garbage public
housing which will promptly be wrecked
by homeless people because a lot of
those homeless people in order to clean
out when actual
need to abide by certain restrictions
but you can't have those restrictions
because you have a legal right to
housing in other words this is idiocy
but here is gavin newsom
doing the idiotic thing because welcome
to california in order to get the job
done we've got to match this new money
with a new legal obligation to address
the crisis head-on requiring that any
new funding isn't replacing existing
spending but creating new solutions some
have recommended a legal right to
shelter I know it's a provocative idea
which has forced this state to explore
the limits of what local governments can
be compelled to do but right now our
imperative I believe must be about
bringing governments together as working
partners not sparring partners in a
court of law
so um if you give everybody illegal
rights of shelter that you're making
everybody sparring-partners in a court
of law that's that's what it does I mean
you've now casted into the courts which
is the entire purpose of course then he
says what if doctors could write
prescriptions for housing what if they
could write prescriptions for housing
what the hell is he talking about now
not to put too fine a point on it but as
you know I have a close relationship
with a doctor a close sexual
relationship with a doctor my wife I
know hot but my wife should not be able
to write prescriptions for housing
that's idiocy she's she doesn't know
anything about housing she doctor she
can read prescription for drugs she can
read prescription for pharmaceuticals
she grant prescription for a follow-up
appointment she can't write a
prescription for a two-bedroom condo in
Studio City what the hell are you
talking about Gavin Newsom
McGavin Newsom doesn't understand how
doctors work so here he is the doctors
should write prescriptions for housing
healthcare and housing can no longer be
divorced after all what's more
fundamental to a person's well-being
than a roof over their head doctors
doctors should be able to write
prescriptions for housing the same way
they do for insulin and
biotic what in the what okay but the
good news is the Gavin Newsom says that
what has really helped Californians is
that we are now providing tax free
tampons and diapers this is what's
helping Californians save money so we've
really we've really fixed all the
problems guys now obviously the answer
to a lot of the homelessness problems in
the state of California is to lower
taxes increased investment increased
investment in development release people
from rent control and criminalize people
who are trespassing or engaging in
public drug use public defecation make
sure that people either are forced into
mandatory drug rehab or that they are
treated in ways that they need to be
treated if they're mentally ill they get
the drugs that they need right but he's
not gonna do any of that stuff instead
he's just gonna talk about how yeah sure
we got hundreds of thousands of homeless
people across the state of California
what if we declared a legal right or
putting on doctors and also here's some
free tampons the working parent with
more money in our pocket
thanks to expanded paid family leave
$1,000 family tax credit in lower costs
due to tax free diapers and tampons yep
well and whoo California man sure
open needles on the streets poop on the
corner well combined stuff with your
kids in residential areas but those
diapers are tax free guys don't you feel
better now don't you feel better this
state is trash it's a good good news why
don't why don't we like take that and
just expand it across the whole nation
Democrats do such a great job they do
such a great job all right we'll be back
here later today with a couple
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow for all of
the recap all of the follow out Bernie
Sanders charges headlong across the
across the nation's Democratic primaries
taking a break
every so often at his Stalin Eska over
near over near Moscow well we'll get to
that tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]